et nous accueillons ce soir notre
terrain du samedi 20 heures marc veyrat
conçoit
[Applaudissements]
alors marc veyrat blake une légende de
la gastronomie française deux fois trois
étoiles au michelin et 3 fois 20 sur 20
au gault et millau internet qui reste
illégale est à ce jour pourtant au début
des années 2000 vous disparaissez des
radars médiatiques
la faute à un terrible accident de ski
là commencent trois ans de souffrance en
fauteuil roulant et sous morphine
jusqu'au jour vous finissez pas
raccrocher les gants la traversée du
désert va durer cinq ans aujourd'hui
vous êtes de retour avec un nouveau
restaurant et vous nous raconter votre
histoire à main
[Musique]
marc veyrat bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes né
le 8 mai 1950 à annecy vous grandissez
près de la clusaz dans la ferme
familiale
et c'est là avec votre grand père berger
et votre mère céline a que vous entrez
en osmose avec la nature les myrtilles
fraises des bois des plantes sauvages
des champignons vous découvrez tout ça
et vous imprégner de ça j'ai eu la plus
belle éducation du monde ouais
l'éducation de la nature et c'est une
éducation aromatiques cette
exceptionnelle et là vous apprenez à
fumer le jambon avec des arômes
savoyarde l'acef de sapins le gène
briller vous apprenez à affiner le
reblochon à préparer les confitures r
les vaches ouais bien sûr on avait des
vaches alors là on est devant votre mère
aux fourneaux vous découvrez vos
premiers émois gastronomique est une
belle histoire à l'adolescence vous vous
sentez mal à l'aise dans les salles de
classe votre père essayer de vous placer
chez des amis restaurateurs
à 17 ans vous quitter le cocon familial
pour une école hôtelière à bellegarde
sur valserine dans l'ain ça mauvais
souvenir ouais on ne met dehors au bout
d'un trimestre parce que j'étais
ingérable en fait mais j'ai quand même
un beau cadre l'entrée de mon restaurant
et c'est le cas c'est la signature du
proviseur qui dit n'est pas fait pour ce
métier doit prendre une autre
orientation
vous êtes viré votre père vous dit marc
tu feras toujours honte à la famille
c'était terrible c'est terrible épée et
l'ag s'est passé quelque chose j'ai
voulu prouver la famille non je ne
ferais pas mais quelle chance qu'il me
dit ça mais qui n'avance pas à l'époque
on vous dit à la maison qu'est ce qu'on
va faire de toi un message plus pour
faire de la loire vous devenez berger
vous devenez moniteur de ski vous vous
êtes même plongeurs à un moment dans un
dans un resto à la crise est comme ça
mais votre fulgurante ascension va
commencer lorsque vous installez dans
une ville à annecy et là vous ouvrez
l'auberge de lérida c'est d'ailleurs là
que vous adoptez votre fameux feutre
noir en mémoire de votre grand père
berger et venait me chercher ouais tous
les soirs au printemps ils venaient avec
des myrtilles jamais des myrtes et ce
chapeau chaque fois qu'il attendait avec
les chèvres les chèvres manger les talus
et ils allaient auprès de l'école ils
m'attendaient la sorte et bien sûr et il
venait il avait toujours un bouquet de
myrtilles qui l'avait ramassée ou un
bouquet de fraise des bois ou un bouquet
d'achillée mais je saurai c'est dans les
bras de mon grand-père n'a ni fil et
j'adorais moment là c'était le coeur dur
antenne
ce qu'on peut dire marque c'est que
bruno le maire a été marqué par sa
grand-mère et vous par votre grand père
voilà bravo les gros par an
alors je visais attention fulgurant
parce qu'en deux ans vous avez deux
étoiles au michelin et vous êtes élu
cuisinier de l'année par le guide gault
et millau
alors la
digue et de déménager dans une
somptueuse demeure au bord du lac
d'annecy à veyrier le lac non
financièrement c'est épouvantable passé
il est bon les banques vous étrangle 1
heureusement troisième étoile au
michelin
ça c'était une bonne heure vous savez
tout le monde d'accord voilà la plus
ouvrait à megève la ferme de mon père
qui reçoit également trois étoiles au
michelin 20 sur 20 au gaultmillau je
crois qu'elle est une première c'est la
première et la seule soir
à ce moment là
hélas
hélas avec le succès arrive la
surchauffe vous commencez à avoir des
projets en chine en tchéquie vous faites
de la pub pour le jambon madrange fait
de la cuisine moléculaire
vous avez une pression à l'époque
monumental passé dix huit heures par
jour si vous faites les 35 heures en
deux jours 18 heures par jour dans la
chaleur des fourneaux jamais un jour
d'absence vous dormez pas et la marque
vous commencé un peu à perdre les
pédales vous dites la tyrannie de
l'excellence on n'imagine pas ce que
sais je
je pense toujours à mon ami bernard lozé
ouais cette pression mais seuls les gens
ne se rendent pas compte cette pression
que l'ona en restauration avec les
guides les critiques gastronomiques mais
c'est un ferme imaginez vous votre
chiffre d'affaires c'est 60% le guide
donc le guide va faire votre chiffre
d'affaires alors vous dites le désir de
rester au top
peut être extrêmement destructeur ah
ouais bon ça m'a détruit j'ai fait une
dépression de cette cyclothymie que vous
dites à l'époque je devenais fou bah oui
complètement et puis 8 janvier 2006 vous
fêtez votre troisième vingt sur vingt au
gault et millau vous avez rassemblé
toute votre famille pour une journée de
ski vous faites un peu la course avec
vous avec vos gens et ancien ancien
moniteur de ski donc voila et là vous
êtes à 100 kilomètres à l'heure vous
prenez une bosse hélas derrière la bosse
il ya votre fille vous fracasser son
snowboard vous finissez dans un pylône
pour trouver tous les deux à l'hosto
elle a rien mais vous vous avez des tas
de fracture la jambe gauche l'épaule
droite et lombaires les cervicales en
vrac la cage thoracique enfoncée vous
dites j'ai vraiment cru que j'allais
mourir là c'était terrible surtout que
j'ai pas perdu connaissance et je peux
vous dire que dans dans le choc chaque
fois que je roulais et que je tapais
quelque chose une pierre ou le
l'obstacle c'était mais c'était
effroyable c'était une brûlure intense
et elle quelque chose d'incroyable le
problème c'est cuit jours après
l'opération
vous êtes de retour en cuisine et là
vous commencez à tourner autour des
fourneaux en fauteuil roulant parce que
vous ne voulez pas laisser vous dit
imaginez qu'un inspecteur du guide mais
sega se présente c'est exactement je
veux être là c'est exact donc vous êtes
là subclaquant show votre fauteuil
roulant mais vous êtes là quand même un
drôle de combat les sens évidemment
parce que votre état ne s'améliore pas
il empire et vous commencez à avoir des
inflammations
autour des fractures bien sûr très très
vite deux algoneurodystrophie surcoût
qui sait d'effroyables sais les
souffrances effroyable là vous décidez
de vous séparer de la ferme de mon père
à megève puis de l'auberge de léry dont
vous rendez les étoiles vous dès les 20
sur 20 et quand vous rendez les étoiles
vous êtes battus pour prouver que vous
étiez capable de faire quelque chose et
dans sur le coup vous rendez tout tout
par obligation plus rien plus rien plus
rien plus rien la redescente et est très
sévère paraissent terribles c'est la
déprime à l'époque et des bruits qui
courent sur vous on vous dit mourant on
dit que vous avez un cancer des poumons
en plus mal et puis un jour un
chirurgien lyonnais nous débarrasse de
toute la ferraille qui encombrent et
votre squelette exactement le professeur
chambat m'a remis debout j'ai souffert
pendant cinq ans et six mois après je
marchais alors là finie la morphine
évidemment vous construisez la maison
des bois qui votent nouveau restaurant à
1600 mètres d'altitude vous construisez
pratiquement de vos mains en tous les
cas vous participez vous prenez la
truelle quoi hein en fait c'est plus
qu'une maison si une espèce de hameaux
avec des écuries une serre un four à
pain des chalets où on peut dormir et
magique des ruches pour le miel on
recrée aux maisons des bois ce que j'ai
vécu dans mon à douala et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je suis l'homme le plus
heureux du monde ah oui alors là bas n'y
a pas de voiture il ya ellul nuls appel
au camp nou à ces vingt couverts pas
plus non ces trois jours par semaine
c'est un bonheur un bonheur absolu on a
là on est devant le mont blanc mais on
est hors du temps on a un aux bêtes on a
nos moutons émules on a nos jardins
l'anglais le problème c'est qu'il ya
deux mois d'attendre déjà pour y aller
oui mais ça on peut vous savez savez
quand on aime on peut toujours
s'arranger voumard on a des petites
tapes dans la cuisine qui se peuvent se
régler les problèmes alors là pas
d'étoilés michelin cette fois
écoutez c'est juste maintenant faut
faire rentrer là dedans à nouveau bien
sûr que les guides sont prêts revenez me
voir à recommencer ouais mais je pense
que non cette chute vous a remis les
pieds sur terre a complètement ouais ab
la chute à tous les cas
intellectuellement cher notre main ouais
maintenant ça c'est clair ouais et puis
on a pris le temps de réfléchir j'ai
plein de choses qui me sont arrivés j'ai
des petits enfants un merveille je
reçois les enfants toutes les semaines
vous rendez compte jeu devient éducateur
c'est la transmission
un peu que je sais je veux que leur
faire savoir leur faire savoir par
exemple que mon papa quand on entre les
vaches n'est ce pas et qu'on mettait la
pénicilline et combes pour quand les
vaches avaient une mammite et bien on ne
craignait pas la vache pendant dix jours
d'accord parce qu'il y avait une
respectabilité du produit de l'animal et
de l'humain et papa nous répéter
toujours ça et on ne donnait pas de
croquettes aux bêtes on n'avait pas de
surproduction on respecte l humain le
prochain et on respectait la terre et je
pense que la politique monsieur le maire
vous avez un travail énorme à faire
parce que nos enfants n'y a pas que
l'éducation nationale il ya surtout
surtout au début la nourriture mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu